okay so muna episode 4 had an ending
that potentially pulled back the curtain
of mark specter's life to show him in an
asylum surrounded by things we'd seen
earlier in the season it was like
finding out your favorite shield agent
had been hydra the entire time and it's
arguably the best disney plus mcu
episode that we've ever had mark finds
himself in the mess hall at a
psychiatric hospital and it's not too
long before he's taken before dr harrow
who tells him everything we've witnessed
so far has been a fantasy that he's
cooked up in his head due to his mental
illness though we get a reveal of
stephen and tarou later on and we know
from the trailers on the show that
things will likely be returning back to
normal well normalish i want to play my
first house advocate and go through the
entire season pointing out every clue
that shows why mark has been in the
asylum the entire time i think you'll be
surprised at how many shocking details
there are in this video and by the time
we get to episode 2 you might even start
to suspect that mark is still just
imagining the entire thing there's so
many minor things that influence what
happens later on and there's such a
strong argument for it that it really
makes me think the episode for ending
might all be true if the creative team
are smart i think they'll even close out
the series by leaving it ambiguous so we
get an inception-esque ending that
really makes us question if what
happened happened or if it's all still
part of the illusion now the first
evidence begins all the way back in the
trailers for the show when stephen said
the following
i have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams hello and welcome this very
much sets him up as an unreliable
narrator and from the off it kind of
makes you question everything that he
sees steven is apparently a sleepwalker
and he says that he ties himself to the
bed so that he can't run away this is
through an ankle restraint that we later
see mirrored when he tries to get up
from the wheelchair and he's chained to
it he also apparently receives postcards
from his mother which he pins up and
these later appear on the whiteboard
that layla stands in front of when
stephen exits his flat we see someone
outside selling brooms and a trolley
full of them is something that's
commonplace at a psychiatric hospital
notice that steven also sleeps in the
clothes that he has on in the asylum he
has not only the white jumper the mark
has on but he also has a darker one
which steven lighter wears when mark
comes across him upon arriving at work a
staff member called dylan comes up to
him and brings up that date which steven
has no recollection of in the hospital
we can catch us sitting there along with
our next character donna who's hugging
one of the cuddly scarab toys that comes
from the gift shop now donna and steven
even talk about tarouette who pops up at
the end of episode four
bring those hippos up here will you yeah
sure
tar wedding the hippo gotta start with
it
this is a pretty big indicator that the
things appearing in the fantasy could be
influenced by what's happening to him in
the hospital and in this conversation
donna says a pretty interesting line
listen if you don't stop nattering at me
i swear i'll shove you in a sarcophagus
now this is quite a big one because when
mark escapes harrow's office he comes
across steven stuck inside a sarcophagus
which is such an amazing call back to
this moment in episode one the steven
graham persona is of course very
important in the show and our first
fourth of all breaking moment comes when
we cutted the film toonbuster which has
a hero called the same thing if we are
taking everything in the asylum at face
value then this actually makes a lot of
sense we learn that it's mark's vhs tape
and if he's carried it around with him
for his entire life then he'd be
completely obsessed with the character
in the comics we learned that steven was
somewhat of an imaginary friend to mark
that he invented when he was a kid in
his room there were indiana jones
posters and the guy was obsessed with
archaeology therefore it makes sense
that if he was going to invent a persona
that he'd bring in elements of what his
interests are and if we're saying this
is all real detail explains why he
creates steven hell he even has the same
accent as steven does
maybe so
you've got pluck
now let's see what we can find on our
friend here harrah also quotes the
villain from this video tape
no tree can ascend to the light of
heaven if it doesn't descend to the
depths of hell now this carl young quote
being used by him and the villain shows
that he sees himself as being reflected
in that character which explains why
he'd be the antagonist in the fantasy
now another detail that harrow has is
that he has quite similar hair to steven
grant in tomb buster whereas in the
office environment it's just slicked
back grant also uses a compass much like
how the golden scarab is used in the
series this leads the character to a
statue of a luna guard and kunshu is of
course worn in egyptian culture the
woman that he later encounters in the
lift also makes an appearance in the
metal and though we only see her from
behind you can tell by her haircut that
it's definitely her now i want to get
into more of a breakdown of the scene
later in the video but i've promised you
episode 2 stuff so we're bloody doing
the episode 2 stuff
we're doing it stop what you're doing
here we go again now episode 2 opens
with stephen getting caught for smashing
up the bathroom in the prior entry this
was because he fought a jackal that
couldn't be seen on camera again further
hinting to us that he's just imagining
the entire thing he's taken into an hr
office and here we find the staff member
with lots of items on his desk that
harold later has the table is also made
of glass and this is the exact same one
that harrell later sits on at one point
the hr head passes forward a pamphlet to
a mental health hospital much like what
we see mark in in episode 4. on the
front of this is a man whose face is
completely blurred and though it's
difficult to make out who this is it
looks a lot like harrow later on hell
when we could to harrow in the office
for the first time he's completely
blurred out much like what we have here
now if we take everything as being part
of the asylum then it's from here on out
that things line up exactly with how a
patient is treated policeman bobby and
billy come to pick steven up and they
handcuff him much in the same way that
orderly is coming to pick up a patient
would they are later revealed to be both
orderlies at the hospital and they even
give the fake surnames fitzgerald and
kennedy which are riffing on jfk's full
name once a patient is picked up by the
elderlies like this they'll normally be
taken to the hospital which is where
they're uncurved and they meet their
doctor for the first time becomes to
them as a friend much like how harrow
does now i want to give a huge shout out
to david lee who sent me an email which
talked about how he'd spent time as an
in-n-out patient at hospitals like this
and how harrow's approach in episode 2
is exactly the kind of thing that he'd
experienced when being dropped off at
one harrow says i'm sorry for the wait
we just needed a chance to
better understand your situation
let's get you out of those cuffs
there you go
thank you both
now let's take this line's meaning if it
was being delivered by a doctor who'd
just come to me they're patient harrow
is trying to understand steven's
situation i.e his mental illness so that
he knows how best to treat him up next
i'm gonna play a clip and i want you to
listen to it in the context that this is
a doctor talking to his patient
just need some help maybe that's right
that's why i'm here
to help
okay what is it you see him you see him
right now of course all right it's all
right
that's all he can do without your help
come it's also at this point in the
series that we learn conscious can't
actually affect the world around him
that much further alluding to this all
being a fantasy now it's at this point
that hara walks him through the
community but if we are taking him as
actually being a doctor then this is
exactly how a person would walk a new
patient through the facility there's a
group sitting in the background
discussing things on meditation pillows
and we also have an area where there are
people who are watching a relaxing
nature film this is commonly used to
calm a patient and show them that it's a
gentle and easy-going environment where
they'll be cared for next is one of the
most common practices that psychiatrists
use when bringing a patient into
somewhere new harrow takes steven to get
some food and this is from the same line
that the others are eating from this is
done to show that the food is safe to
eat because others are consuming it and
therefore this is a safe space consuming
yeah look i hadn't done a pun for a
while yeah the video was getting way too
serious just let me have my fun anyway
all of the tactics here are clearly put
in place to make steven feel safe and
welcome and they're all applied by
psychiatrists whenever a new patient is
brought in now it seems to cement that
this is all the asylum when things take
a turn for the worst and stephen makes a
break for it with layla the pair escape
the main hall and run up to what appears
to be a storage room filled with creepy
bodies now the next reveal is pretty
mind-blowing and this room itself is
actually the exact same one that is
later used as harrow's office the two
columns are there and the recesses in
the wall also appear in his office
confirming that these are indeed one in
the same mooneye of course also has a
white costume which we see the patients
all wearing and this is reflected in the
little figure that mark makes of the
character now if we continue this idea
on episode 3 then there's a really
interesting scene in the pyramid of giza
mark is taken before the annie ad and at
this point they summon herrera to come
forth mark accuses him of trying to
resurrect omit but it falls on deaf ears
which does seem a bit suspicious they
take it less seriously than my dad took
my mother's pregnancy and just brush him
to the side as soon as harrow brings up
his did you think that they'd at least
investigate it but this is something
that we also see in mental health
facilities if we keep up the idea that
this is all in the hospital it not only
explains how mark is able to travel
great distances in seconds but it also
explains what the any ad themselves are
this situation is exactly what would
happen if a patient accused a doctor of
abuse or neglect a hearing would be held
with the doctors peers and supervisors
where both would give their case david
told me about what normally happens in
situations like this and he said that
the doctor is pretty much always
believed above the patient which is
exactly what happens here now if we take
leila being trapped in the fantasy 2
then there's quite an interesting bit
that happens at the start of the episode
she meets with a passport forger who
creates her a new one this is the same
woman that we see drawing a picture of
konchu later on in episode 4. mark never
meets this person in the series so it
doesn't make much sense as to why she'd
be in there unless leila is part of it
too layla also eats marshmallows off her
desk and these are what she snacks on in
the hospital scene now at this point
mark or well jake
well i think it's jk he and laila meet
and then she and mark travel to meet
anton mogart aka midnight man they're
then greeted by his bodyguard who makes
a big appearance at the hospital this is
the guy who can be seen pushing the
cupcake caught these cupcakes of course
tie back to the chase in germany which
itself shows up as a painting in
harrow's office there's lots of weird
things that happen in this scene such as
steven randomly just waking up in the
hills the gods then pop out of a window
on a castle which is revealed to be
miles away and harrow's followers will
look to him as someone in authority
stephen has weird conversations with him
that only makes sense if his present
version was in the past and there's also
this idea of dreams and waking up lace
throughout
[Music]
[Applause]
wow that's a good one now episode four
could very much be seen as an allegory
for mark and layla working together to
get into certain parts of the hospital
that they really shouldn't be in they go
through the long corridors and abandoned
passages in an attempt to get to the
center of the mystery alexander's tomb
this is littered with ancient artifacts
and these later show up in harrow's
office it's during this time that harrow
somewhat snaps leila out of the fantasy
by talking about her father this is done
in a very similar manner to the reveal
and [ __ ] island to snap teddy out of
the fantasy in many ways [ __ ] island
and the scenario here could be very
similar with doctors in a psychiatric
hospital allowing one of their patients
to live out a fantasy in order to
discover a truth about themselves this
could be used much in the same way to
reveal that mark kill layla's father
well rather jake did now i know it's
bushman in the comics and that they'll
probably end up teasing that but there
are fan theories that jake was the one
who did it so i might as well drop them
in whilst we're still doing theory time
theory time their time every time
it also shouts this at her
wake up
[Music]
[Applause]
a huge shout out to ryan arie from
screen crush for pointing that out and
he also brought up the night sky being
turned back in this reality episode iv
itself starts off with steven being
knocked out after the whole situation in
which they rewound time so potentially
this could be further carrying on the
dream now if you think about it turning
back the night sky will completely break
all time and space within the mcu so
they're either gonna have to say it's
all a fantasy or wreck on it before the
end of the show anyway the way that mark
transitions from the tomb to the
hospital could also be a hint at what's
really going on he's shot by harrow and
then he falls backwards if this was
happening in a hospital then this whole
situation could be a metaphor for
sedation and this shock could actually
be a needle at sending him under after
he and layla have run amok laila doesn't
need one of these because harrow has
already explained the truth to her and
she's accepted it without the need for
drugs to calm it down now we're gonna go
into the hospital bit but before that i
wanna hear your thoughts if you've been
enjoying the breakdown then please hit
the thumbs up button but if you think
it's all a bunch of mephisto then the
thumbs down is there for you we'd also
really appreciate the subscription
because we do videos like this every day
not this not this good but nearly as
good so yeah definitely stay locked in
the channel for more mediocre content
now in the hospital we have crawley who
was the living statue that stephen would
bear his soul to this is very similar to
what he'd do to a patient in a hospital
and there are ways that they can meet
there's also a man playing with a
rubik's cube which has one side that's
all white much in the same way that
stevens did when he was trying to solve
in episode 1. as we scan the room we can
also catch a clock with moon crescents
on the hands possibly influencing
moonlight clocks have appeared
throughout the series and if you've been
following them they've actually been
counting up to something that we'll talk
about in one of our upcoming videos on
the show now there's a man tending to
some plants much like what there was in
harrow's facility and the goldfish the
bowl for this sits on top of several
books which all appeared in steven's
apartment there's harrow's cane his
sandals and of course all the links to
omit hell harrow pretty much judges all
the patience like he judges people using
the scales it's all connected
yes it is and it all kind of ties it
together to hammer home this idea that
steven or mark has been in the asylum
for the entire season the series is
really detailed and like i said earlier
in the video i think that disney will
probably continue down the path that's
the most obvious with mark escaping the
hospital and getting revealed that it's
a fantasy this is something that has
happened in the comics and the entire
twist in the episode is based on the
jeff lemire run this saw mark being part
of an institution overseen by a
psychiatrist named dr emmett who had two
orderlies called bobby and billy she was
later revealed to be omit and they were
the jackals much like the two jackals
that we've had in the series so far now
this entire thing was an illusion
located in a place known as the other
void denmark had a psychological trip
through his past which it seems like the
next episode we'll be doing due to what
we've seen in the trailers he did manage
to break out of it and i think the
season will wrap up with him escaping
this place and then stopping harold from
shooting purple lasers in the sky and
resurrecting omit however as i mentioned
i do think they'll leave it ambiguous
come the end of the show much in the
same way that we had the spinning top
and inception i think we'll close out
with either something like the moonlight
figure or the b22 bingo ball so you'll
always have this thing where you can see
the events as being real but there'll be
a strong case that it's all in mark's
imagination anyway i hope you enjoyed
the breakdown as it took a lot of time
and effort over the weekend to go back
through the series and point this all
out let us know your thoughts in the
comments below and i hope you join us
for our episode 5 breakdown later on in
the week we are in a competition right
now giving away three copies of
spider-man nowadays home on the 15th of
may and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the theories we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want some emails to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
episode four which will be linked on
screen right now we've also got one for
the batman which is equally as good as
this video i know i know they're
normally not that good but that one's
quite good so yeah go check out one of
them right after this without the way
thanks for clicking this i've been poor
see you next time take care peace